Niccolai: Hi. My name
is Marzia Niccolai,
and I'm a Developer Programs
Engineer here at Google.
Today we're gonna
talk you through
how to create and manage
your Application
with Google App Engine's Admin.
Console.
You can get started with
Google App Engine
with any Google account
or Google Apps
for your domain account.
Go to appengine.google.com
and sign in with your account.
If this is the first time
you've signed in,
you'll be asked
to verify your account via SMS.
But because I've already
done that,
I can go ahead and Sign in
and create an Application.
The first thing
you'll be asked to do
is choose an Application
Identifier.
This is the unique string
that identifies your Application
in our system.
You can check the Availability
just by clicking on the button.
Next, go ahead and enter
your Application's Title.
Here you also have the option
to set your Application's
Authentication Options.
By default,
we've selected Google Accounts,
but if you have a Google Apps
for your domain,
you can also
set your Application
to authenticate against
accounts from that domain.
Just click the Edit button,
click Restrict to the following
Google Apps domain:
and enter your domain
information.
However,
for this demonstration,
we're just gonna go back
to Google Accounts
since this is the default.
Then accept the terms of service
and click Save.
As you can see, your Application
was registered successfully.
Just put the App ID
in your App.yaml file
when you upload
your Application.
Because the Application
we just created
doesn't have any data,
now I'm gonna show you
how to manage an Application
with an existing
Application App gallery.
When we click on the App ID,
we'll be taken to
the Applications Dashboard.
This is an overview
of all the system
traffic information.
The first graph that we see
is related
to the Applications Traffic.
It shows the Request per Second
over a 24-hour window.
We can also select the dropdown
to see what other graphs
are available.
As you can see,
we can also see the number
of Errors we receive
as well as the number
of Megacycles Used
and Quota Denials
our Application has received.
Just select the desired graph
to bring it up.
The next section
is our Application Quotas.
Here we can see an overview
of all the system resources
we've used
with respect to the free limits
set by App Engine.
Let's scroll down
to look at the information
related to each of our
Applications handlers.
The first table we see
is the Current Load table.
This gives a breakdown
of all of the handlers
of our Application
that have been visited
since midnight.
We see the name
of the handler on the left,
and on the right,
we see columns
related to the resource
usage.
For each handler,
the first thing we see
is the request rate
for that handler.
Then we see
the total number of requests
that Application handler
has received since midnight.
The next thing we see
is the Average CPU
consumed by that handler
over the past hour.
And finally we see
the % CPU
that handler has consumed
since midnight.
The table on the right shows
our most errorful handlers.
On the left-hand side,
we see the handler name.
Then we see the total
number of Errors
it has received
since midnight
as well as the percentage
of requests to that handler
that have received Errors.
This is all the information
that's available to you
on the Dashboard page.
Next, we can look at our logs
to see more in-depth reporting
for each of our requests.
Just click on the log's link
on the left-hand side.
By default, we show all of
the requests to your Application
that have resulted
in an Error.
But we also allow you to filter
on different Severities.
Just click on the dropdown
to choose the appropriate
level of filtering.
Let's go back
to the Error logs.
Here we see the 20 most
recent requests
that resulted in an Error.
If we wanna see more
information about the request,
we just click on that line.
This expands the section
and gives us more
in-depth reporting
as to the Error we received.
As you can see,
in addition to the information
that we received
about the Error,
we also provide
some information
about the amount
of CPU resources
this request has consumed.
Also remember
that you can download your logs
using appconfig.pi
and analyze them offline.
Next, let's look at
the information available
in our Datastore section.
If we click on
the Index link,
we can see the status
of all of the Indexes
that we've specified
in our index.yaml file.
Next, we can go to
the Data Viewer
to see the information stored
in our Applications Datastore.
When we click on
the Data Viewer,
we can see the information
in the Data Viewer
either by Kind
or by Querying.
Let's look at our dropdown
to see what kind of Kinds
we specified in our Application.
We can also click into
an individual Entity
to see information
related to that Entity.
If we wanna look
for a specific Entity,
we can do a GQL Query.
Just click on the Query button
and enter your GQL Query.
When you run the Query,
the results will be returned.
In the Admin Console,
you can also Administer
all of your
Application Settings.
If we click on the
Applications Settings link,
we have the ability to change
the Application Title.
The next thing we can do
is add new Administrators
to our Application
by clicking on
the Developers link.
When you add new Developers
to your Application,
they have full administrative
power over that Application.
Simply type in a valid
Google account...
and click the Invite link.
This will send an email
to the Developer
asking them to accept
your Invitation.
Once the Developer
accepts your Invitation
to administer your Application,
their status will move
from Pending to Active.
In order for the new Developer
to have full
administrative powers,
you'll need to redeploy
your Application.
With Google App Engine,
we allow you to set Major
Versions for your Application.
You can manage
these Major Versions
by clicking on
the Versions link.
Whenever you upload
an Application
with a new Major Version,
that Version
will appear on this screen.
The Default Version
of your Application
is what your users will see
when they hit your URL.
But if you'd like to see
your code running in production
and aren't quite ready
to make it live,
you can also view other Versions
of your Application
by clicking on the link
next to the Version number.
When you click on this link,
this will take you to that
Version of the Application.
Non-active Versions
are only available
through clicking on this link.
Once you're ready
to make a Version Default,
simply click
next to the Version number...
and click
the Make Default button.
This Version is now the Version
your users will see
when they visit your URL.
Finally, with Google App Engine,
if you do not wanna serve
your Application
off the appspot.com domain,
you can add your own
Google Apps Domain.
Simply click
on the Add Domain button.
This will ask you
to enter a Domain Name.
Click
on the Add Domain button,
and you'll be taken to
your Google Apps login page.
Sign in with
an Administrator account.
Here, after accepting
the terms of service,
enter the subdomain
where you wish to serve
the Application
and click
Activate This Service.
Your Application
will now be served
off of this subdomain.
And that's really
all there is to it.
For more information,
visit appengine.google.com.
Thanks for watchin'.